banks are not your friends that's alex
mashinsky in the shirt founder and ceo
of celsius one of the largest crypto
lending platforms and on june 12th his
company surprised customers when it
unexpectedly announced it was pausing
all withdrawals swaps and transfers
between accounts due to extreme market
conditions for reference this year
bitcoin has lost more than half of its
value and another popular cryptocurrency
ether has fallen around 70
celsius decision to freeze customer
accounts has rippled across the
cryptocurrency industry
shortly after its announcement another
asia-based crypto lender called bubble
finance announced that it is also
suspending withdrawals unlike banks
which are fdic insured crypto lenders
like celsius lack the legal protections
that are built into the traditional
financial system and as the crypto
market continues to tumble many users of
celsius and the exchange coinbase are
beginning to wonder
if these crypto platforms go bankrupt
what happens to my assets
celsius is one of dozens of unregulated
lenders and lending platforms that have
emerged in recent years touting high
returns to investors who are willing to
lend their digital assets
celsius promised customers annual
percentage yields as high as 18.6
that's a lot
more than customers can get from regular
bank accounts today here's how that
works
customers deposit their cryptocurrency
in the celsius system in exchange for a
yield this is essentially an unsecured
loan and in order to earn a return the
company lends out assets to other users
and puts customer deposits in often
high-yield high-risk decentralized
finance investments when the system is
working correctly celsius says that
customers can expect approval for their
withdrawals within 24 hours but as
cryptocurrency prices continued to fall
customers started to withdraw at a rate
celsius couldn't keep up with celsius
does not have enough liquidity meaning
readily spendable cryptocurrency on hand
to hand back to the customers the
company has since hired restructuring
lawyers to advise on possible solutions
for its mounting financial problems
one of the financing options included a
financial restructuring meaning that the
company could potentially file for
bankruptcy and if that happens users
could face big losses
according to celsius's terms of use
users that deposit assets in the earn
service grant the company all right and
title to such eligible digital assets
including ownership rights that document
also calls out bankruptcy explicitly
saying in the event that celsius becomes
bankrupt enters liquidation or is
otherwise unable to repay its
obligations any eligible digital assets
used in the urn service or as collateral
under the borrow service may not be
recoverable you will likely not see a
line like this in a user agreement for a
bank since most banks are fdic insured
so what does that mean for users
based on celsius terms of use in the
event of a bankruptcy customer who
deposited cryptocurrencies into celsius
accounts may not be able to get their
money back because they would be
considered essentially unsecured
creditors and even if they were to file
for lawsuits against celsius they might
not have a great chance of winning that
legal action similarly the exchange
coinbase addressed bankruptcy in its
quarterly filings adding a disclosure
based on sec accounting guidelines
released in march coinbase made the
disclosure that in the event of a
bankruptcy the digital assets that
coinbase holds for its customers may not
really belong to the customers coinbase
noted that the new language in its
financial report could lead customers to
view its service as more risky and less
attractive coinbase ceo brian armstrong
has come out and said that the
likelihood of the company going bankrupt
is extremely low and the company is in
very good financial conditions but he
made the disclosure
just for the purpose of transparency
nearly one month after the bankruptcy
disclosure on june 14th coinbase
announced it was laying off around 18 of
its workforce armstrong said the
decision was made to ensure coinbase's
health during this economic downturn but
if a crypto platform like celsius or
coinbase were to go bankrupt it wouldn't
be the first to go under in that way
in 2014 mount gox then the largest
crypto asset platform worldwide filed
for bankruptcy before ultimately filing
for liquidation later that year the
collapse of crypto exchange monk goggs
back in 2014 also report across the
industry it caused the price of bitcoin
to plummet
and brought about
so to speak one of the first crypto
winters in the industry a rehabilitation
plan for affected mount gox users was
not confirmed until last fall
cryptocurrency as an industry still
lacks comparable regulation and
protection to traditional financial
institutions but a recent bill looks to
change that senators cincia loomis and
kirsten gillibrand proposed a bipartisan
crypto bill dubbed the responsible
financial innovation act which aims to
provide a comprehensive regulatory
framework for the crypto industry
while the bill was released around the
same time that coinbase made its
bankruptcy disclosure it is not in
direct response to the platform's
announcement the bill is not expected to
pass and other lawmakers have not signed
on to it as for celsius the company is
under investigation the texas state
securities board said it has opened an
investigation into celsius over its
decision to freeze customer accounts and
is working in conjunction with new
jersey kentucky alabama and washington
you